that socks and the texas rangers to
finish this one up native aldi on the
hill 10-8 coming into 391 era nate
taking a tough two to nothing loss at
yankee stadium last time out the red sox
really need him today in there
that's a split finger that acts like a
slider pulls it on the inside corner
could have gone either way he gets it
perfect pitch two down for lace garcia
has come bursting through
up the middle it got through of aldi
somehow
and kiki zips it in time one two three
start for colby on the mound today for
the rangers it'll be his 15th start he's
been hot here in august
this fastball's popped up to center
field dj peters is out there battling
the sun and he makes the catch one man
out one on first inning no score
fastball out of the strike zone jd
martinez chases it he is down on strikes
for the second out here
in the first inning nice pitch from
colby going up the ladder
left-hand batting and nathaniel lowe
trying to put away the number four
hitter
and does set him down to curveball
bottom looking second k for nate
curveball on the corner it does catch
the corner t.j peters former dodger
swing and a miss he puts away peters
with a yacker oh he's got a yacker today
his stuff has gotten better you know
these all these pitches seem to have
gotten better this curveball is nasty
rodrigo banning eighth centerfielder
today 277 with 11 home runs
swinging a drive out to right
guys
red sox lead it two to nothing
the inning's been kind of building to
something like that
he got a hanging hook and he left he was
swinging he left earth he does that a
lot he'll come out of his shoes boy did
he pick the right time to do it how
about that swing i mean he just aired it
out beautifully that pretty so one on
one out
well this one is lined to the left side
that'll be a base hit not hit very hard
at all ibanez will stop at second and
hernandez as we know a very good contact
hitter not a lot of swing and miss gets
himself a little bloop single over the
head of rafael devers two on one out
kind of falafel
on the leap and that's gonna turn into a
double play allard reaches into his
glove goes overhead with the wind and
the pitch swinging a mess fastball a
little bit in there gets hernandez as
colby allard records his third strikeout
he's got one in each frame so far four
consecutive quality starts without a
walk here's a swing and a miss a
schwarber went fishing for an allard
curveball so back-to-back strikeouts for
colby allergenic i see the right filler
all for one today
that was 99 miles an hour say hello to
that that was hot strikes out garcia
there's a four-seam fastball got some
hump on it
foul tip all in the glove nicely done
jason martin over at first and here's
the pitch ground ball hit to the left
side devers will go no we will not go
across a diamond as he bobbles the ball
on the exchange and it'll likely be an
error against rafael devers two-nothing
boston here top of the fifth and here's
the pitch and jose it's ground ball why
the third past everest but bogart's has
it in the hole throws the first and it
goes off the glove of dalbeck at first
a run is home over to third base on the
play goes solac trevino is safe on
another boston error
and the red sox lead is cut to two to
one that'll be an e3 they will charge
stallbeck with the error first and third
and as the battery has struck out in
singles
it's bunted but it's strong play at the
plate
so like trying to get back to third down
getters will launch and get it
now play over there between first and
second
and tagged out by schwarber so a little
comedy on the base pass as well for
texas
they tried to bring that run home on a
bunt fail to do it
a little safety squeeze and they got
it's a double play as it turns out on a
safety swing socks on top of the rangers
here 2-1 in the top of the six
came out of his shoes came up empty too
there's some hump in this exchange here
with garcia he strikes him out two gone
he went and got him a couple of
fastballs and this ball's a strike right
down broadway again but that's got some
hair on it nathaniel lowe
and three two
he got him he struck him out another
fastball yes
here's hunter renfrow for two
that one hit a long way high and deep
kiss that one goodbye
number 23
for a hunter renfro and he doesn't hit
any cheapies none of them are cheapies
once again gets a cutter felt high and
he launches it to the seventh sox with a
couple of big flies today to lead three
to one jason martin with a pair of
singles
3-2 he blew him away there another
fastball
two down boy he's had that fastball late
in this game
last four strikeouts have been on the
fastball
he will not block you three two
powder river see ya it sounds up solac
on the day he's over two he's reached on
an error in a one-two home
and a ground ball to second
[ __ ] gets him one two three
each of the last two innings in fact for
nate he met a board for jd martinez
who's overdue today's over three here
comes a 2-2
and there it is again swung on and
missed and that is the slider from brett
martin just at a time that pitch starts
looking a little bit more like a cutter
because now he's got to try to get
through xander bogart's with two outs
and there's a good fastball triple to
the right side fielded by low gets the
bag in time and the yang is over so very
nice job by brett martin to get through
some tough hitters socks in front three
one we go to the eighth inning adam
alamino in send up kinder philippa on
the day over three and here is that 2-2
pitch and a ground ball up the middle
that's going to get to center field for
a base hit trevina will pull up
at second base and so a couple of base
runners now with two outs in the eighth
inning for the rangers the doley's
garcia this has been the spot for garcia
where he has been really strong late in
the game
adevino's 2-2
big swing and a mile high pop-up
coming on verdugo creeping in
and that is all
strange too matt barnes will be the new
pitcher looking to close this out matt
fanning all three many face to finish
off friday's shutout barnes has got
problems right now low at second peter's
on it first and martin will be the
hitter
joining him as he struck him out
with the yakker
yes he did texas trying to rally in the
ninth one away 3-1 boston here's the 1-1
there's another breakable ground ball up
the middle stopped by
bogarts flipped a second and hernan
excuse me arroyo could not hold on and
what looked like was going to be an
amazing play turns into an infield hit
for nick solak and so would his bases
loaded with one out for the rangers here
we go andy ivanya's with an opportunity
now he is here comes the 1-1 and this
one is hit to right field in the gap
deep and one hop and over the wall it'll
be a book rule double
for andy ibanez right on time the
rangers have tied this game
you just talked about the clutch hitting
of andy abanyas he comes up big once
again gary whitlock has to come on here
matt barnes blowing a save three on two
out two in 3-3 in the top of the night
here's the one-two pitch
[Applause]
they leave him loaded they do tie the
game extra innings so you do get that
automatic runner it is isaiah connor
philippa who is over at second base
right now what the red sox have done
here with whitlock ground ball to the
left side that's going to get through
isaiah kind of filetpole rounding third
he's going to try to score here comes
the throw home not in time when the
rangers take the lead here in the top of
the 10th inning an rbi single
from nathaniel lowe so now the tying run
at third comes e02 and this slider is
grounded to third here comes the runner
home strong throwing a pick great job
jose trevino
yani hernandez with a great defensive
play but on the other end jose trevino
picks and tags and arroyo is eliminated
what a huge play
santana the o2
swinging the high deep drive out toward
the triangle racing peters back there
back down he can't get it here comes
zander third he's gonna score denver
saves the red sox and ties the ball game
he saved him he did once again the
slider he threw him another slider he
crushed this slider
so that will load up the bases with
nobody out and travis shaw can be the
hero 3-2
[Applause]
how sweet is that for travis shaw
talk about a walk-off piece the ultimate
walk-off
slamming
travis shaw he hit the daylights out of
it the red sox pull it out eight to four
the final
a walk up grand slam by travis shaw